صباح الخير يا عادل صباح الخير يا راويه
هي فعلا العربيات اسعارها ارتفعت بشكل
جنوني تسبب في ركود كبير جدا في السوق
دلوقتي يعني في فبراير
او في ابريل عشان نكون دقيقين تم بيع
حوالي 5100 سياره مقارنه بالعام الماضي
اللي اتباع فيه حوالي 16,600 سياره ففي
انخفاض وركود كبير جدا في سوق السيارات
العربيات بتزيد بيزيد سعرها يوم بعد يوم
بشكل مخلي الناس مش عارفه تواكب الاسعار
دي غير طبعا الاوفر برايس ومطالبه التجار
دايما باسعار زياده لان العربيات مش
متوفره وبيوفروها بعد شهور كتير وده اكيد
راجع لازمه الدولار وبتتابع كمان العربيات
المستعمله عماله تزيد فما حدش عارف يجيب
عربيات خالص طيب موضوعنا الثاني ايضا لديك
في مصر موضوع عن فتاه مصريه انتظرت 22 عام
ولكن لماذا انتظرت في القصه يا ندى
الحياه دي قصه يعني اطفال كتير
القصه كلها بتدور حوالين زوجين اتجوزوا
بعقد عرفي في سنه 99 في يناير وخلفه لطفله
دي في اكتوبر برضو في نفس السنه وبعد كده
سجلوا زواجهم بعقد رسمي في سنه 2002 فالاب
انكر نسب الطفله وفضلت 22 سنه بتحاول ان
هي تثبت نسبها لحد ما في الاخر طبعا قدرت
تثبته لكن ضاع يعني حقوق كتير جدا في ال
22 سنه دول يعني هي دلوقتي بتحاول تعوضهم
والموضوع ده يعني تسبب في ضجه كبيره جدا
على السوشيال ميديا كمان لانه الازهر
النفسي
والمعنوي والحياتي حتى الاجتماعي للبنت هو
قصه لناس كتير شبهها ففي تحرك برلماني
كبير
هو كمان يعني هذا يمكن بيصير جدل موضوع
قانوني فيما يتعلق باجبار اي شخص على اخذ
فحصه لاثبات النسب شكرا جزيلا لك يا ندى
في على هذه المعلومات وهذه القصص المثيره
شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات